تحكم تطبيق تشتركون فيه عادل يمكن انت
مش حاسبهم حتى والله عرف عددهم ولا
انا اللي على التلفزيون ولا اللي على
الجهاز
الموبايل او النقال كتير لانه مشاهدين ان
اشترك احيانا في تطبيق ما للاستفاده من
الخدمه المجانيه المحدوده ثم ننساها ونقع
في فخ
الخصم التلقائي بضعه الدولارات هنا بضعه
الدولارات هناك تطبيق بودكاست هنا واخر
موسيقى
هناك ايضا خدمه لبث البرامج والافلام
واخرى الكتب الصوتيه واكيد من اللياقه
البدنيه حدث ولا حرج ولا غرق في عشرات
التطبيقات الاغراءات لا تتوقف والاشتراك
الشهريه تلقائيه في ثواني معدوده
مع كثره الاشتراكات يصبح من الصعب تتبع
جميع الخدمات التي ندفعها ندفع مقابل لها
او حتى ملاحظه رساله البنك التي تنوه
بالخصم وتتوه وسط زحام بقيه الفواتير
والمدفوعات اليوميه
السؤال هل نحتاج لكل هذه الاشتراكات ربما
لا وما الافضل السنويه منها ام الشهريه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو المستشار المالي
طارق زياد حياك الله هلا كيفكم شو
صباح الخير صباح الخير ولا اسبوعي ولا
يومي والله لاهد ولا هاد ولا تشترك لا
بنشترك بس
هاي الشغله صارت عند الناس يعني وسهوله
الاشتراك والدفع يعني ما في ابلكيشن تعبيه
خلاص
عجبني والناس ما بتقرا يعني شو
اذا نزلته هل انت رح تدفعه ولا لا فهي 30
درهم 50 درهم بس تضربها على عشر ابليكيشن
على 12 شهر بتطلع اغلى من انثى الذهب يعني
الواحد يروح يدخر احسن ما يروح فلوسه
بالفعل ولانهم مقسمين على عده تطبيقات اشي
على التليفون على التلفزيون ممكن جدا انه
ما نشعر بقديش فلوس عم ندفع عليها طيب شو
الحل لهذا الموضوع هل انه احنا مثلا نحدد
انه لازم يكون في عنا عدد معين فقط من
الاشتراكات الشهريه ما نطلع عنه ام انه
يعني في كتير شغلات ممكن نستغني عنها ولا
نحتاجها على حسب الفائده يعني مثلا في
اليوم برامج تعليميه خمسه درهم عشره درهم
الواحد وقت يسجل يحط عنده على النوت انه
انا سجلت بهذا 10 دراهم بالشهر ويراجع هاي
النوت كل شهر يعني متل ما نحن بنعمل
حسابات للشركات الواحد يعمل حسابات شخصيه
له يعمل هذا جميل لكن واقح الامر ما يحدث
انه انت تشترك ببرامج تلفزيون وتطبيقاتها
كثيره
ايضا على الموبايل اشياء كثيره حاب تتعلم
رياضه حاب تتعلم شيء تقول والله انا ليش
اشتراك لمدرب يجيني اشترك بهذا التطبيق
وتروح تنتقل الى تطبيق ثاني كيف تحد شلون
تع ايدك انه ما تكبسها والله هي مثل
الادمان صايره خلص انا
بالمشترك طبعا وسهوله الاشتراك برجع بقول
سهوله الاشتراك اليوم اذا بصلك لينك تعبي
وتدخل الاسم وبرقم البطاقه بتقول لها خلص
ما بدي اياها الواحد عن جد يراقبه وهنا
اذكياء يعني بيخصموا الاشتراك اول الشهر
بيكون نازل الراتب 30 درهم ما رح يحس فيها
على زحمه الكريدت كارد على المسجات ما بحس
فيها بس اخر السنه بتجمع فالانسان لازم
يعمل كنترول سيلف كنترول على نفسه ويقول
انا بدي ولا خلص لا خلص
لحتى يقدر يعرف هل انا فعلا محتاجها ولا
لا ويقدر يعني يخلص من هذا الاشتراك ولكن
انا بحس انه في بعض الشركات او بعض
التطبيقات بتخدعنا عندها خدع معينه بحيث
انه بتغرينا بانه اول شهر يكون
مجانا وبعدين بنبلش ندفع ولما يخلص هذا
الشهر بنصير بصير صعب انك توقف هذا
الاشتراك يعني انا جربت في كتير بعض
التطبيقات مش عارفه مش عارفه اطلع منها
مضبوط وانت بتقولي مو محرزه مثلا اقعد وجع
راسي وايميلات وتليفونات على 300 درهم
بالسنه بس هي وهو هذا الجهل دائما هو اللي
بيسبب مشاكل بجميع المجالات بس الواحد
يقرا لا حتى نحن بنوقع فيها بس المشكله
على السرعه والسهوله الواحد ما بيقرا
التيمز ومتى ما علق خلاص يعني في علم انا
بعرفهم وانا واحد منهم مرض حتى اطلع من
ايضا بس مجرد ما تحطه على حسابك في
منهم اذكياء طيب كيف راح تتغل
يقرا هل هو قادر يوم القيامه يطلع من هذا
الشيء ولا لا هي صفه الكيرن في مزبوط
مضبوط هو الاغراءات والسهوله
انتبهوا اذا وخليكم دائما يعني تكتبوا
يمسك دفاتره الشخصيه مو اكثر شكرا
للمستشار الماليه طارق زياد الوتار شكرا
جزيلا الله يخليك شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات